el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva continúa su gira por
Sudamérica para fortalecer la
integración económica esta vez en
Montevideo Uruguay
quiero construir definitivamente la
unidad de América del Sur
América
la unidad de América Latina luego de la
Cumbre de la celac Lula se enfoca en
mercosur busca persuadir al gobierno de
Luis lacalle Pou para que este no Avance
en solitario en un acuerdo comercial con
china Lula es consciente del riesgo que
corre la unión aduanera de mercosur
compuesta por Brasil Argentina Uruguay
Paraguay si se concreta el tratado entre
Montevideo y Beijing el presidente
uruguayo calmó la preocupación de su
homólogo brasileño nosotros pertenecemos
al mercosur Y tenemos esa vocación
incambiada moderno
flexible y abierto al mundo sin embargo
la calle Pou reiteró que Uruguay Busca
abrirse al mundo aunque esto implique
negociar acuerdos comerciales por fuera
de mercosur Uruguay también ha
solicitado unirse al acuerdo integral y
progresista asociación transpacífico una
apertura que Brasil insiste en realizar
conjuntamente
es importante abrirse más a otros
pueblos
quiero decirle al presidente que estamos
Totalmente de acuerdo con la idea de
discutir la innovación y la renovación
del mercosur
de acuerdo durante su paso por Uruguay
el presidente brasileño se encontró con
el expresidente uruguayo José Mujica
quien destacó la labor integracionista
de Lula señalando que está por encima
las cuestiones ideológicas
las enormes dificultades que tiene